schönen guten abend der laschen haben
uns heran seit wann hand aufs herz
wussten sie eigentlich dass sie kanzler
von deutschland werden wollen heute
haben sie es offiziell gesagt aber
wussten sie dass schon als die
parteichef wurden in der minute
na ja also wir sind ja noch nicht am
ende dieses prozesses wir sind mit der
csu weiter in gesprächen aber natürlich
weiß man wenn man vorsitzender cdu
deutschlands wird nach einem langen
wettbewerb dass sie auch die erwartung
da ist dass man bereit ist kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu werden und
insofern war mir schon klar also den
letzten wochen und monaten war ihnen
eigentlich klar dass sie es werden
wollen dass sie kanzlerkandidat werden
wollen aber man hat es noch nicht gesagt
nein mir war immer sehr sehr wichtig und
das gilt bis zur minute dass diese
entscheidung mit der csu zusammenfällt
juni oder immer stark wenn cdu und csu
zusammen standen
es gab schwierige zeiten große konflikte
die uns allen noch bekannt sind und
jetzt sind wir so eng beieinander
inhaltlich bei den grundthemen jetzt
anstehen
und deshalb müssen wir auch diese
personelle frage gemeinsam lösen
das letzte mal als ich im studio waren
nach dem cdu-parteitag da hatten sie
diese erkennungsmarke von ihrem vater
dabei der bergmann war die hatten glück
gebracht um parteichef zu werden wie
viel glück brauchen sie jetzt für morgen
für das präsidium also erstens habe mein
vater die wieder an seinem schlüsselbund
da hatte er sie ja abgemacht also war
nicht so nötig die sie haben alles dabei
und zum zweiten ja weiß ich ja wie viele
landesvorsitzende die sich auch schon
öffentlich zum teil geäußert haben
über diese frage denken und ich denke
dass wir morgen gut beraten
keinen beschluss fassen denn wir wollen
mit der csu gemeinsam auch abgestimmt
agieren aber doch eine empfehlung wie
wir weiterreden und wie wir dann zur
lösung aber wie läuft das ab gehen sie
dann da hin und sagen bitte sprechen das
vertrauen aus oder was war denn da haben
ja schon viele eure eigene meinung die
sie dann artikulieren werden und das
würde ich morgen einfach mal ab war aber
sie brauchen schon einen
präsidiumsbeschluss werden sie darum
bitten
ja ich sage es wird keinen beschluss
geben das haben markus würde und ich
verabredet es wird ein meinungsbild
eingeholt die lage werde erörtert was
eigentlich jetzt das beste und wie
finden wir einen gemeinsamen weg aber
nur mehr eine mehrheit haben sie schon
positiv
mal von aus aber wir werden das morgen
sehen ich will dem jetzt wirklich nicht
vorweg greifen
das präsidium seien gerade erst gewählt
es ist ja auch auf dem parteitag gewählt
worden und danach der bundesvorstand und
da sind alle landesvorsitzenden drin
alle vereinigungs vorsitzenden also das
ist schon die breite der partei
und das will ich mal abwarten dann frage
ich noch mal anders hat ihnen
irgendjemand aus der cdu gesagt dass man
sie nicht möchte als kanzlerkandidat
also aus dem präsidium
ich habe das bisher nicht gehört aber
ich würde trotzdem jeden ermutigen das
auch zu sagen wenn er das anders denkt
es gibt einzelne abgeordnete aber das
ist ja auch normal bei 400.000
mitgliedern und vielen abgeordneten aus
den unterschiedlichsten regionen dass
bei jeder seine präferenz hat nur am
ende müssen wir es zu einem gemeinsamen
ergebnis führen
und das ist unsere absicht wenn sie
jetzt sehen was markus söder den
csu-chef angeht ja auch heute gesagt hat
er will es machen
er hat lange gesagt mein platz ist in
bayern das sehen sie wahrscheinlich
genauso oder also ich finde er hat heute
gesagt er würde es gerne machen er würde
es auch können er hat auch hohe
zustimmung
so dass wir dann abgewogen habe was ist
ja nicht der richtige weg und das ist
halt 15 landesverbänden der cdu dann die
csu in bayern ist muss man
zusammenführen und dass er ein
exzellenter ministerpräsident ist und in
der bundespolitik eine riesenrolle
spielen könnte er unter innenminister
werde ich habe in der lehre das will
also ob man als ministerpräsident in
einer bundesregierung eintritt das ist
eher selten der fall
man hat ja als ministerpräsident ein
großes land zu regieren
aber er sitzt im koalitionsvertrag und
nichts geht ohne die csu keine einzelne
entscheidung keinen koalitionsvertrag
gar nichts und das hat er auch noch
einmal sichtbar gemacht sie haben gerade
die zustimmungswerte selbst angesprochen
das ist ja das worauf markus söder immer
wieder verweist dass er sagt das sei
eben entscheiden heute gab es eine
umfrage der bild am sonntag die zeigte
in der konstellation gegen die möglichen
kandidaten kommen sie auf 13 oder 14
prozent markus söder beide male auf 37
prozent wie viel sorge muss das der cdu
machen
das musste ja gar keine sorge machen
weil ich schon so viele umfrage
schwankungen in meinem leben erlebt vor
meiner wahl zum ministerpräsidenten vier
wochen vorher lag die spd 12 prozent vor
und darum dass alle in der cdu hannelore
kraft war die beliebteste deutsche
politikerin
man muss bei seinen inhalten bleiben die
cdu muss geschlossen sein und es kommt
auch darauf an wie hält man eine solche
partei zusammen
friedrich merz norbert röttgen waren
meine gegenkandidaten
wir haben danach den weg
zusammengefunden friedrich merz
unterstützt mich jetzt also das sind
nicht unbeträchtliche dinge die auch zum
wahlerfolg beitragen integriere wir
haben sie das eigentlich geschafft dass
briten naja wer hat da ein interview
gegeben was mich in der klarheit auch
überrascht hat aber wir sind immer
miteinander gut klargekommen und mein
mein credo war immer wir brauchen die
christlich-sozialen die konservativen
und die liberalen in der cdu und wenn
die alle zusammenstehen dann haben wir
auch eine chance zu gewinnen und jetzt
noch mal klartext morgen cdu-präsidium
abends csu präsidium haben wir morgen um
diese zeit einen kanzlerkandidaten der
union wir werden ja auch über den weg
wie wir das machen noch einmal morgen im
präsidium sowohl in münchen als auch in
berlin miteinander beraten
und mir ist immer wichtig dass wir das
verbinden
auch mit den inhalten um die es geht um
die ging es heute bei dieser in diesem
gespräch mit dem vorstand der
bundestagsfraktion
wie kommen wir nicht durch die pandemie
gut wie wird unser management besser was
machen wir nach der pandemie wenn
wirtschaftliche probleme drohen was ist
mit dem klimawandel und den arbeit aber
muss man am ende gemeinsam entscheiden
also muss es irgendeine art sitzung
haben traditionell gibt es am ende in
einen gemeinsamen beschluss der
präsidien das war bei jeder
bundestagswahl
ich glaube seit 1949 so und das würde
ich mir diesmal wenn diese woche das
weiß ich nicht
jetzt hat markus söder in der
vergangenen woche immer wieder gesagt
das ist wichtig sei dass die kanzlerin
ein wichtiges mitspracherecht hat jetzt
hat die kanzlerin heute
sie unterstützt hat von einem brücken
lockdown gesprochen und hat indirekt
bayern kritisiert fühlen sie sich
gestärkt von der kanzlerin
die kanzlerin hat heute deutlich gemacht
dass die idee von brücken lockdown den
ich ja angestrebt dass wir nämlich
schneller entscheiden dass das eine gute
idee war das hat über
dann bist du da auch gesagt also wir
sind in der frage einig dass wir jetzt
zu schnellen entscheidungen kommen
müssen und da dass jedes land
unterschiedlich ausgelegt hat die
notbremse das hat sie heute domain
erinnerung aber es war eine lange
diskussion oder wurde bisher ein
geheimnis ob die kanzlerin in eine
ausbildung in neuss wollte sie sicher
nicht und der einzige streit war ja die
ob es möglich ist in der notbremse in
geschäften einen besuch mit terminen
möglich zu machen wenn man ein
testergebnis hat so diese regelung und
bayern dann auch eingeführt also
insofern haben in der ähnliche auslegung
da gehabt wenn sie sich durchsetzen
sollten jetzt als kanzlerkandidat haben
sie dann die volle unterstützung der
kanzlerin ja davon gehe ich mal aus dass
die kanzlerin den unterstützt der cdu
vorsitzender ist und daran habe ich auch
keinen zweifel
wie viel prozent müssen sie erreichen um
kanzler zu werden dadurch das kann man
nicht sagen das ist ein parteien system
was in großen wandel ist wir erleben
dass die spd mit der frühen des
kanzlerkandidaten so gut wie keine
punkte aufgeholt hat der
hauptwettbewerber werden jetzt die
grünen seien aber ich finde wir dürfen
auch diesen sozialen themen nicht
vernachlässigen und wer dann am ende die
größte erwartung hat das land danach gut
zu führen
dieses modernisierungs jahrzehnt zu
gestalten der wird gewinnen und ich bin
sicher
rot rot grün wird uns um jahre
zurückwerfen
und deshalb müssen wir alles tun dass es
dafür keine mehrheit gebe es denn
rot-rot-grün tatsächlich die koalition
die wirklich am gefährlichsten für sie
es auf der anderen seite oder könnte es
dann womöglich eine ampelkoalition sein
oder andere kunde es muller nicht
spekulieren das hängt ja auch von den
themen ab wie die parteien
zusammenkommen
ich weiß nur für deutschland wäre rot
rot grün die größte katastrophe und
geist muss die union stark genug die spd
vorsitzender diesem wochenende gesagt
dass das ihre favoriten kollektives
gerade zusammen jetzt nimmt das ganze
fahrt auf wenn die spd vorsitzende
erklärt kein problem zu haben mit der
linken deutschland zu regieren
wie bei den kern außenpolitischen fragen
eigenartige positionen hat gegen die
nato ist gegen die europäische und
jungen keinem
einigungsvertrag zugestimmt hat den wir
in europa hatten dann wird das eine
muntere debatte und gleichzeitig ist für
uns wichtig auch die abgrenzung nach
rechts dass die afg heute beschlossen
hat mit eu austritt und ähnlichem wäre
eine andere republik und hier müssen wir
den kern unserer republik betten und
auch darum geht es in dieser
bundestagswahl
sie sprechen debatten an nächste woche
die bundestagsdebatte
infektionsschutzgesetz sie wollten das
ursprünglich mit einer mpk jetzt soll es
eine ausgangssperre in bezirken geben in
landkreisen geben die über 100 in der
instanz sind
erklären sie uns mal warum soll ein
rentner ehepaar zum beispiel abends
nicht mehr allein durch ein dorf gehen
können wenn die institute höheres warum
muss es diese ausgangssperren geben und
sind sie wirklich so ein richtiges
mittel ja das gesetz ist ja ist noch
nicht in allem formuliert es gibt es aus
den ländern sehr viele unterschiedliche
akzente die man da noch mal
berücksichtigt haben will dann ist die
verfassungsrechtliche frage muss der
bundesrat zustimmen oder nicht und auch
diese ausgangssperre wird man nochmal
rechtlich erörtern müssen geht das
überhaupt so und wie macht man ja ich
habe sie bisher ja nie eingeführt
außer in einigen kreisen wo die inzidenz
völlig aus dem ruder gelaufen ist daheim
für sie eingesetzt wäre das dann ja da
haben wir haben immer jeweils es kommt
ja auch das infektionsgeschehen an das
war vor ein paar monaten geringer
heute ist der wert höher wenn sich ganz
deutschland darauf verständigt für eine
bestimmte zeit damit wir unter 100
kommen auch das in betracht zu ziehen
würde das am er persönlich nicht
scheitern aber sie sind eigentlich
persönlich nicht so richtig dafür oder
man muss kompromisse machen uns ich
mache alles mit was wirklich hilft das
geschehen herunterzubringen das beispiel
dass sie sagen das rentnerehepaar das da
spazieren geht das ist nicht das problem
natürlich aber insgesamt verhindert
bewegung verhindert begegnungen die man
am abend in den privathaushalten noch
hat so schildern es die kollegin die
dass er intensiv wie in bayern oder in
baden württemberg schon genutzt wenn sie
jetzt die nächsten wochen sehen erleben
wir in deutschland auch noch im mai so
ein knallhart lockt die menschen fragen
sich ja wie lange geht das noch mit der
brücke wollte ich ja sagen lieber jetzt
noch mal richtig runter
und dann die neuen möglichkeiten nutzen
impfen mit tempo was es was das zeug
hält
tag und nacht am besten dazu testungen
auch verpflichtet und in den schulen
eingeführt sowie arbeitsminister
wehrpflicht werden die betriebe sagen ja
sie werden es machen ich hätte die
freiwillige lösung besser gefunden
aber das ist jetzt auch im paket drin in
den schulen muss es verpflichtend sein
und es muss zweimal die woche auch die
tests bereit stehen denn kinder sind im
moment wie manche werte seien bei der
mutante stärker betroffen und das dritte
ist endlich die digitalen lösungen
nutzen wie die lukb oder andere
innovative modelle wo man direkt
infektionsketten nachverfolgen kann und
im mai haben wir dann auch noch da also
jetzt tun wir erst mal alles dass die
zahlen runter kommen und je schneller
wir sie runter bringen desto schneller
können wir auch in ein stück normalität
gehen
wir werden carola noch das ganze jahr
haben aber wir können weit sein beim
impfen und wir können auch vielleicht
diese hohen instanzen die wir im moment
erleben hinter uns lassen und ab wann
werden die gelten können sie das sagen
die neuen maßnahmen das hängt davon ab
wie schnell dieses bundestag und
bundesrat entscheiden alle sagen es muss
ganz schnell gehen
es muss trotzdem gründlich sein wir
dürfen nicht wieder so eine panne
erleben wie bei der oster ruhe wo man es
drei tage später zurücknehmen muss also
gründlich schnell und dann bundestag und
bundesrat möglichst zusammen herr
laschet zum abschluss was machen sie
jetzt heute abend heute nacht noch um
die letzten möglichen zweifler zu
überzeugen greift man dann auch mal zum
telefon trifft man sich da rufen sie
ihren vater noch einmal an um sich
glücklich diesen heute abend werden wir
uns nochmal sehr intensiv mit corona
beschäftigen auch unter ein paar
ministerpräsidenten sprechen wie wir
denn da weitergehen
die sachpolitik und diese krise
beschäftigt glaube ich die menschen mehr
als die kanzler kann arbeiten sie können
mir nicht erzählen dass dann in dieser
frage wenn sie sich jetzt mit ein paar
ministerpräsidenten unterhalten
da die k frage keine rolle spielt oder
das wird man sehen aber die ist ja jetzt
heute auf einem weg da ist erkennbar was
morgen passiert die korona frage ist
noch nicht gelöst und die ist wichtig
was ist denn erkennbar genau was dann
morgen passiert der sich und wird sich
damit beschäftigen
die siegerin ich will keine prognose
wann ich will einfach abwarten so viel
respekt ist auch vor dem höchsten
führungsgremium an gesagt herzlichen
dank armin laschet cdu chef heute bei
uns im studio
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren